[Musique]
bienvenue dans la grande interview nous
sommes avec son altesse la princesse at
the edge il m'a envoyé spécial du
président du burkina faso pour le
changement climatique bonjour votre
altesse merci d'avoir accepté
l'invitation alerte et france donc merci
de m'avoir dans votre très distinguée
programme un pêcheur c'est mental alors
le regard de la princesse musique que
vous êtes d'abord sur cette période
trouble que nous traversons tous cette
pandémie de kobe de 19 qui touche encore
une partie du monde l'amérique mais
aussi l'afrique
bah écoutez c'est bien sûr c'est une
catastrophe humanitaire
mais l'humanité c'est toujours repris à
tous est toujours ressorti meilleur de
tous et ses catastrophes naturelles ça
fait partie de la vie hélas ce ne sera
pas la dernière fois mais il faut que
nous en tirions les leçons pour pouvoir
rebondir et pour les générations
suivantes ça c'est vraiment la chose ce
que quelque chose de positif
puis sortir de là plus de solidarité et
le clac au vide a démontré sa que
l'humanisme que chacun de nous à et cap
hume peuvent faire sortir cela ça c'est
très important
justement sur le continent africain il
semble que la pandémie commence à
progresser mais c'est vrai que c'est un
continent qui est moins touchée que les
autres
quelle est votre lecture de cette
situation vous savez nous avons eu et
bola moi personnellement j'ai
expérimenté cela quand j'ai commencé à
voyager quand je voyage en afrique et
surtout au burkina faso dès le début de
la pandémie avant que l'europe ne
mettent les protections barrière mon
pays l'avait fait et au retour j'en ai
parlé au collège je dis voilà quand je
suis arrivée à l'aéroport de ouagadougou
avant même de descendre de l'avion n'a
pris mon adresse savoir
après tales qui j'étais après ma
température donc je pense que nous avons
appris et c'est pas un hasard si
l'afrique n'a pas été autant touché
c'est parce que hélas nous avons appris
de la manière la plus difficile nous
avons perdu beaucoup des frères et
filles des fils d'afrique du hezbollah
donc c'est ça qui est fait aussi c'est
pas un hasard parce que nous avons
appris des leçons du passé
c'est ça alors vous dites qu'il faut
refaire ressortir quelque chose de
positif
finalement de cette crise sanitaire
mondiale c'est vrai qu'en en ce qui
concerne le climat
ce qui est fou c'est qu'avec cette crise
du coronavirus et l'arrêt d'une grande
partie de l'économie mondiale il semble
que les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre ont baissé de manière
significative les quatre premiers mois
de cette année
est ce que c'est réellement une bonne
nouvelle ou est ce qu'il faut craindre
le pire que l'on voit avec la reprise
économique
je pense que tout le monde a vu ça on
respire mieux
le ciel est beaucoup plus bleu et on
prend le temps aussi de ralentir en
prend le temps de mon pote prendre un
recul pour voir vraiment où on veut
aller qu'elle vit nous souhaitons avoir
et je pense que ça c'est le côté si je
puis dire si je puis me permettre avec
tout le respect et la douleur que les
familles ont vécu avec la perte des
leurs le côté positif c'est que on va se
dire on peut faire autrement c'est
possible de télétravailler par exemple à
nous communiquons avec la digitalisation
nous ça fait émerger aussi la proximité
les commerces de proximité de faire
comprendre aussi que ce que les
écologistes a parlé dans le temps
recevront centrer vers ce qui est utile
ce qui est nécessaire prend vraiment
tout son sens et que on peut aussi créer
de l'économie au niveau local stimuler
ce qui existe localement tout en
respectant l'environnement
les deux sont possibles y'a pas une
dichotomie on peut faire les choses on
peut voyager autrement on peut
influencer localement et importer
globalement et je pense que le fait que
nous avons eu ce problème de la pandémie
qui a été mondiale va amener d'autres
façons de faire des affaires et je pense
que le monde ne sera plus comment voit
on ne fera plus les affaires a de la
même manière et les choses vont beaucoup
se concentrer sur l'humain et sur
l'environnement
et ça c'est quelque chose de formidable
alors c'est vrai que sur le continent
africain il ya beaucoup d'informations
que vous dites là est ce que cela vaut
également pour votre continent votre
pays également le burkina faso justement
c'est l'occasion de se formaliser comme
le savait depuis des décennies je me
bats au niveau législatif et ça a été
pris en compte alors de fans se
développe à addis ababa qui aboutit sur
addis ababa hadj ndao où le secteur
informel a été pris en compte parce que
c'est l'occasion vraiment aussi de se
formaliser
quand on est on est on n'a pas un numéro
fiscal
ça veut dire qu'on n'existe pas même si
on contribue ça veut dire que
législativement on n'existe pas hélas
c'est ce sont là c'est la réglementation
donc il faut vraiment je pense que j'ai
cette idée là comme ça peut-être qu'on
va penser que je suis farfelu pas du
tout ce serait bien qu'on ait un numéro
fiscal dès la naissance
ça et qu'on puisse activer telle qu'on
active à ce rang santé les fascine kart
ds dépend des bébés en est avec son
numéro fiscal et qu'on peut se
formaliser dès qu'on commence à faire
des affaires
adapté contextualiser à notre contexte
parce que l'afrique n'est pas l'europe
n'est pas nazi
nous avons notre culture et nous et la
législation doit s'adapter à notre
culture
la finance aussi de s'adapter à nos
modes de vie par exemple tout le monde
utilise en afrique maintenant le le
mobile banking le paiement par la
digitalisation mobile c'est une
invention africaine mais souvent on
oublie mais c'est venu d'un prêt d'un
réel problème et les africains se sont
mis ensemble pour trouver cette solution
avec m-pesa avec nos frères du kenya
mais maintenant vous avez apporté c'est
une solution africaine dont on doit
aussi s'en réjouir et d'en parler et je
pense que toutes les bonnes choses que
l'afrique fait doit aussi s'en réjouir
et être content des bonnes choses
qu'elle fait aussi pour accélérer le
commerce dans le monde et la
digitalisation vous savez l'afrique est
un bassin d'innovation et souvent on ne
le met pas en exergue
il ya beaucoup de nos frères de nos
compatriotes dans la diaspora
que ce soit dans l'aéronautique dans
l'espace dans le dans tout domaine dans
le domaine scientifique
nous avons eu une plénitude de capacité
dont nous-mêmes africa nous ne prenons
pas ça à bras le corps et c'est pour ça
que je remercie vraiment son excellence
roch marc christian kaboré d'avoir su en
tirer aussi profit de mon aura au niveau
international de ce que je fais pour des
babas que tout africain où qu'ils soient
se sentent ambassadeurs de l'afrique
ambassadeur de son pays et c'est
ensemble qu'on arrive et cela va même
case enfin la formidable zèle les cas
qui a été donc tous les africains sont
venus ensemble en juillet c'est
extraordinaire mais c'est le moment
vraiment de prendre à bras le corps de
démontrer qu'on n'est pas dans le
conflit mais surtout ensemble et nous
sommes ouverts vos affaires ce n'est pas
la charité
on est ouvert aux affaires ouvert au
monde l'afrique est ouvert à des femmes
formidables comme vous et moi
pour ce pour faire avancer avec les
frères et soeurs nous serait à digérer
vous portez princesse daisy mal
la corde pour le climat sur le climat au
nom du burkina faso justement un mot
quand même sur cet accord vous parlais
tout à l'heure des innovations on va
certainement parler en pour lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique
la coop 26 elle n'aura pas lieu à
l'automne mais à l'été 2000 21 alors
qu'on attendait quand même des ambitions
revues à la hausse en matière de
réduction de gaz à effet de serre qu'est
ce qui va se passer maintenant puisque
là on est dans un contexte d'une forte
récession au niveau mondial
je pense que vous savez c'est pas c'est
pas une mauvaise chose ça va permettre
par exemple dans les négociations quand
les pays en développement les pays moins
développés les petites des petites rides
aussi qu'un un pays insulaire qui
souffre ce que nous disions dans les
salles de négociation qu'il faut cette
solidarité est que nous ne sommes pas
responsables mais nous avons des
solutions par rapport à la halle haas
écrit station carbone par rapport à la
sécurité alimentaire des innovations
indigènes qui peut faire changer le
monde
maintenant avec cette pandémie ça amène
les pays à bien nous comprendre ma table
voilà les africains les indigènes ce
qu'il proposait comme solution c'est
faire cette solution là qu'il faut aller
en adaptant le crédit carbone et non en
utilisant aussi celle ce crédit carbone
comme comme garantie ça ça a été
vraiment ma défense aussi avoir une
leadership au niveau africain
parce que depuis la nuit des temps je
dis vous savez moi même étant de de la
famille royale mais aussi les garanties
c'est pas c'est pas seulement du ressort
des pays occidentaux
mon propre grand-père avait à constituer
un stock d'or qui devait être uniquement
utilisé qu'en grand canton compte que
quand tu as des pandémies comme celle ci
comment s'en sortir donc c'est lé plus
ni moins que ce que
la bank mellat fmi ou d'autres
institutions
le fonds de garantie fin nous avons
douze ans une civilisation très ancienne
l'afrique est une est une civilisation à
des connaissances nous avons eu des
premières universités mais il faut
vraiment comme on dit toujours si tu ne
sais pas où aller regarde d'où tu viens
et être fiers de la o2 d'où tu viens
et ça il faut jamais oublier ses
origines
une question importante c'est justement
le financement et les engagements pris
par les pays plus développés vis-à-vis
des pays moins développés notamment les
pays africains est ce que ces pays
développés vont pouvoir s'acquitter de
leurs engagements financiers
vous savez moi ma politique ça c'est mon
opinion personnelle
il faut aller vers le secteur privé
c'est s'éteint c'est un gros plan
d'affaires moi je considère le package
de climat l'accord de paris comme un
grand package d'affaires pour que les
africains s'en sort donc il faut un
plaidoyer pour avoir un accès aux
financements à un taux acceptable
comment pour comment pouvons-nous
compétition quand on emprunte quand nous
et a même un point à 6%
comment est ce que vous pouvez comment
vous pouvez re nouer cet argent là à
votre secteur privé pour qu'il puisse en
sortir
là est la clé si par exemple nous
arrivions à avoir le même taux d'emprunt
que les autres pays on pourra s'en
sortir c'est c'est là la vraie claque
laisser l'un la solution c'est pas
d'aller mendier pour avoir quelques
miettes vous rappelez des objectifs du
développement from being soucieuse ou en
sommes-nous là c'est ce même des
millions parle même pas de milliards
mais des millions pour les package de
dissimuler
là où le reprenait à 540 humilié
milliards de package ou les dettes
va être rachetée par la banque centrale
européenne où en sommes nous en a fait
c'est d'essayer de voir ces modèles et
de contextualiser avec avec nos états
qu'on puisse par exemple quand des pays
leurs indicateurs macroéconomiques sont
les mêmes que d'autres pays parce que
ils sont dans le continent africain ou
ailleurs donc la législation diffère moi
je pense qu'il faut une certaine
solidarité à ce niveau là pour permettre
l'accès au financement pour que les
jeunes et les femmes
puis aller vers puisse créer leur
entreprise et créer de la richesse
ça c'est le maître mot création de
richesses valeur ajoutée transformation
votre altesse on va poursuivre dans un
instant on va marquer une courte pause
et on se retrouve tout de suite sur rt
france reste avec
[Musique]
retour dans la grande interview avec
notre invité son altesse la princesse
amazigh m'a envoyé spécial du président
du burkina faso pour le changement
climatique en ont parlé avec vous
justement des enjeux post coop qu'ovide
19 des enjeux concernant le changement
climatique
on évoquait cet accord sur le climat
vous parliez du financement et vous
dites que l'afrique ne doit pas mendier
je voudrais votre point de vue sur les
polémiques autour de l'allègement de la
dette
quelle est votre lecture justement de de
cette problématique là est ce que c'est
un espoir une chance d'une solution pour
les pays africains
l'important c'est l'accès au financement
auto pour qu'il me permettra qui
permettra aux entreprises locales de
pouvoir créer innover et exporté au sein
même de la région et à prendre à bras le
corps embrasser la z liga ça c'est la
solution quand vous créez que vous payer
des taxes
c'est excellent le reste vient comment
est ce que les pays comme l'asie du sud
est
singapour taïwan comment est-ce qu'ils
s'en sont sortis c'est par rapport au
secteur privé ne gère pas ce que je
pense que se focaliser uniquement sur
l'allègement de la dette nous nous
permettra pas de nous en sortir ça c'est
mon opinion personnelle parce qu'à
partir du moment qu'un pays peut mettre
sur la table
dire que voilà j'ai tant de personnes
qui sont formalisées qui ont un numéro
fiscal qui paient leurs taxes
croyez moi que quand vous êtes autour de
la table des discussions votre voix
compte
c'est le secteur privé qui aidera nos
états pour avoir l'autre leur vraie
place dans l'aréna internationale avec
leurs pairs et être considérée tel qu'il
se doit et le secteur privé africain est
derrière ces chefs d'état il faut
vraiment considérer votre secteur privé
venir en aide
avec des votre signature souveraine pour
aller chercher l'argent où il se hisse
ce trou dans les marchés financiers
il ya des investisseurs qui semblent
acquis sont prêts à investir les
étudiants nos enfants sont éduqués et
ils sont prêts à travailler ensemble
le le sud le nord sont prêts à
travailler ensemble
il faut se focaliser sur le secteur sur
le sellette vous identifier
vous dites qu'il faut se focaliser sur
le secteur privé africain que les
gouvernements doivent travailler avec ce
secteur privé mais on a vu que dans le
cadre de l'accord sur le climat à
l'engagement des gouvernements africains
qui attend beaucoup quand même
de l'extérieur on parlait de
désengagement financier par exemple des
pays développés oui bah justement c'est
pour ça si vous attendez regardez par
exemple si je prends le secteur informel
en afrique c'est le secteur qui s'en
sort toujours quand il ya les chocs
exogènes et endogènes
pourquoi parce qu'elle est habituée à
s'en sortir par elle même il faut
commencer à se dire à se baser sur le
peu que j'ai c'est 100 francs que j'ai
et bien il faut que je regarde comment
est ce que je vais employer ces 100
francs pour qu'il devienne mille francs
et qu'ensuite je puisse aller de l'avant
et c'est vers ça ils font vraiment chose
c'est le paradis il faut vraiment
changer penser hors de la pop penser
autrement et je pense que la nouvelle
génération pour ce que je vois en tout
cas ils sont dans cette dynamique là il
faut aller chercher de l'argent avec le
secteur privé même africain parce qu'il
faut pas oublier il ya un secteur privé
africain
il ya des financiers africains qui sont
prêts eux aussi à investir mais il faut
avoir cette plateforme qui va permettre
à ses investisseurs locaux de pouvoir
créer de la richesse au niveau local et
à voir les multinationales de demain moi
je crois des grandes multinationales
vont sortir de l'afrique par adam lang
dans le secteur agricole
j'en suis convaincu
nous avons des terres arables nous avons
nos sols qui ne sont pas polluées et
nous allons dans l'air biologique pour
pouvons exporter la sécurité alimentaire
s'est pas tout simplement quand on
n'arrive pas à à faire pousser nos
fruits et légumes
mais quels types de fruits et légumes
sur caleçons nous ne faisons plus que
l'afrique peut se positionner de manière
très intéressante et vois pas ce que le
son que nous avons c'est de l'argent
est ce que cette question est ce que la
question du climat qui vous tient à
coeur justement s est une priorité au
pav réellement pour les pays africains
aujourd'hui particulièrement dans le
contexte que l'on connaît
cc c'est réellement une priorité parce
que le climat change
nous agriculteurs ne peuvent plus
compter totalement sûr mère-nature
concernant l'eau donc là les innovations
comme les pompes solaires par exemple
pour l'irrigation en train quand et pour
avoir deux trois fois la possibilité de
de pouvoir récolter et de vendre ça ça
permet aussi de pouvoir stocker les les
denrées agricoles ça c'est très
important et aussi planter plus d'arbres
et ça c'est ce que nous faisons burkina
par exemple si je prends l'exemple de
sawadogo yacouba qui a et il ya eu le
prix alternatif du prix nobel qui a pu
[Musique]
arborer à plus de 40 ha ha sur une
vingtaine d'années
vous voyez que des solutions sont
possibles et ce sont des solutions
africaines qui sont maintenant
implémenter partout ailleurs qu'on
appelle la nature besson luz bat ça
l'afrique
elle est par nature nous savons déjà
vivre avec notre nature nous savons
comment nous en sortir et la question
aussi des déchets plastiques des déchets
que nous que nous ne nous ne créions pas
mais que nous devons
aménagé qui veut nous viennent
d'ailleurs tout ça ce sont des questions
mais je pense que le législateur nos
députés aussi très sabra le corps en
venant avec des lois claires pour
respecter la convention de bâle par
exemple la convention de barkin que
quiconque produit des déchets doit
s'assurer de pouvoir les les recycler
donc vous savez les lois existent et une
question d'implémentation et de contrôle
sur tout le contrôle est important c'est
pas que les législations n'existe pas
mais souvent le contrôle manque alors
puisque vous parlez des énergies vertes
on voit que en europe par exemple c'est
le cas en france
les autorités veulent intégrer cette
question des énergies renouvelables pour
relancer aussi l'économie post que vides
quelle est la situation en afrique dans
votre pays par exemple le burkina faso
puisque vous dites est à juste titre que
il y a un réel potentiel en matière
d'énergie verte sur son continent
oui c'est un c'est un domaine vraiment
qu'ils qui créent de l'emploi déjà parce
que ça permet de transférer des
connaissances de former à plus de jeunes
parce que nous avons nous sommes
il ya beaucoup de nos villages nous
avons huit mille villages au burkina
faso notre ministre bachir ouedrago a
mis en place le batave sur la ba cap qui
permet avec les système de pay as you go
pour permettre à tout un chacun de
pouvoir avoir de l'énergie en mettant en
place des garanties pour permettre aussi
un secteur privé qui va émerger sous ça
c'est de la création d'emplois ce sont
des exemples concrets que nous prenons
à coeur et qui créent de l'emploi pour
nos jeunes en milieu rural et surtout
créer des coopératives au niveau de nos
villages non seulement pas de l'énergie
pour l'énergie cre mais a surtout aller
vers l'énergie pour des trous pour la
solution productive pouvoir par exemple
alléger nos femmes qui qui devait moudre
avec la force mécanique à des bras le
cran maintenant avec la mécanisation par
le solaire c'est possible et aussi
pouvoir tisser des pagnes tissés comme
j'ai comme j'ai là maintenant avec de la
mécanisation ça c'est possible
le lagence national de l'électrification
rurale
mais tout cela en place nous avançons et
il ya des bonnes choses qui se passent
dans nos villages et pas seulement qu'au
burkina partout en afrique les
présidents prennent conscience qu'il
faut vraiment reçu réindustrialiser
parce que vous avez nos pays africains
c'était avec commencer une dynamique
d'industrialisation et elle a été
désindustrialisé et là je pense que
l'aco vie va permettre c'est très
injuste réalisation ou pas non seulement
pour pour l'afrique mais relocalisés
aussi les créations d'emploi et ça que
ce soit la france d'autres pays prennent
en considération parce qu'on a vu que
quand on délocalise aussi un homme de
trop massivement ça devient ça peut être
très compliqué et c'est ce que nous
vivons au jour d'aujourd'hui et je pense
que cela ne veut pas dire qu'on ne doit
plus commercer avec
les différents pays mais commercer de
manière différente qui permettent à tout
à chacun d'avoir un travail décent un
salaire décent qui va lui permettre de
survivre de vivre pas seulement de
survivre parce que souvent les salaires
que nous avons en afrique
hélas ça permet tout simplement de
survivre mais pas de vivre je pense que
le salaire qui permet de vivre ça c'est
le plus important
mais justement on vous dit qu'il faut
agir au niveau local vous même vous
l'avez fait puisque vous êtes à
l'initiative d'un programme
mama light qui consiste vous allez nous
expliquer un peu peut-être c'est
d'amener un peu de lumière et dans les
milieux ruraux cmr un programme qui a
été saluée au niveau onusien saluée
comme l'une des solutions les plus
innovantes
jusqu'à présent pour atteindre les
objectifs de développement durable
mais est ce que véritablement c'est
possible d'accélérer ce schéma là dans
les milieux ruraux dans l'informel sur
le continent africain
merci beaucoup pas pour cette d'avoir
signalé cette initiative malade pour
l'énergie durable
justement nous avons au niveau de la de
la cedeao avec le centre des énergies
renouvelables et de l'efficacité
énergétique est basée à part à praia
sourd pour ramener l'initiative malade
pour l'énergie durable au niveau de tous
les pays de la cedeao avec le west
africa sur la pac qui a été adoptée le
12 février à praia le 28 février pardon
à praia lors de son conseil
d'administration avec la création nette
d'emplois dans chaque pays de la cedeao
de 1 million en formalisant avec la
coopérative digital et l'accès aux
marchés pour pouvoir justement à céder à
cet open de d'affaires que crée la z les
cas et de pouvoir aussi travailler avec
les universités au niveau international
notamment sera à l'université de delft
aux pays-bas avec lesquels donc nous
nous avançons
ce sont des innovations
africaine et j'espère vraiment que tous
les jeunes qui m'écoutent à travers
votre kanak
venez avec nous comme on le dit vraiment
c'est avec émotion vous est excellent ne
laissez jamais personne vous dire que
vous ne valez rien je suis passé par là
et je continue toujours
mais avançons et avançons ensemble avec
des passes que la paix ne vient qu'avec
le commerce
même là au dessus en son temps le disais
c'est avec le promesses qu'on avance
le commerce c'est la paix c'est la vraie
indépendance financière
quand je promène avec vous il ya une
relation de confiance qui s'installe et
il n'y a pas de hiérarchie de je te
donne donc tu fais ce que je veux comme
si je commets nous devons toujours
trouver un consciencieuse et plus nous
allons plus le monde va aller vers le
commerce
vraiment tout va se tout va se résoudre
moi c'est ma ccma c'est mon intime
conviction et avec le travail que je
fais avec l'initiative malade pour
l'énergie durable
vraiment j'ai vu cela ça fonctionne
donnant la chance à tout un chacun et
croyant en nous croyons en nos capacités
à notre humanisme que c'est possible
c'est nous et personne d'autre un tank
humain qui pouvons faire ce qu'ils
pourront faire la différence et nous
avons cette chance là et nous allons
avancer
j'en suis convaincu merci beaucoup à
vous votre altesse princesse a pesé
jigme à pour cette grande interview
accordée à rtl france
merci à vous et merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi une grande interview que vous
pouvez retrouver sur nos réseaux sociaux
et en podcast
merci de votre attention et à très
bientôt
[Musique]